man I I was heading up the stairs and
Erica Brown said Lori kilmartin's here
and I was like a kid at Christmas I was
so happy I was so happy you were here I
didn't know if you'd be here you know no
I have to Hefner does hang out as a man
[Applause]
and and that's an analogy you can take
all the way
I'm well into my 80s and I walk around
in a robe
and it's really questionable it's
something that won't age well
um no I'm uh I was so happy that you're
that you're here and I miss you I mean
I'm being completely I was not raised to
speak this way but I love you and I
emotional
no I'm serious it was beaten out of me
but yeah but I love you and I'm such a
such a admirer and fan of yours and I'm
just when so when you were here I was
like I'm crashing you know that used to
be I didn't do that that used to be a
tradition in Show Business that you
would oh yeah uh a celebrity would crash
another show and we had it happen a
couple of times way before you showed up
yeah we had Milton Berle just crashed
onto our set oh my God and um it was
with him
I remember first of all
um it's such a great story well he he
came it was the thing to do back in yeah
right in the 40s and 50s and and 60s if
if a star of miltonborough's uh you know
caliber saw that a lot a light was on
that said they're shooting well hit you
just walk in yeah with cigar and mouth
and the band immediately kicks in and
people freak out so um we're doing the
Late Night show and the double doors and
all of a sudden this would be really
early on 1994 maybe the door is just and
I later heard from a page the page who
was there the NBC page was outside and
the NBC page saw Milton Burrell had just
finished something at live at five you
know and he had just finished doing
something and he walked out and he's got
his cigar and he sees the light and we
had Letterman's studio so it was always
like this sort of well-known talk show
Studio he saw the light on anyone what's
going on in there and they said oh
they're taping Late Night with Governor
O'Brien and he went I'm going in and he
just kicked the doors open of course the
band immediately went into a song I
forget what his song was I think it was
oh yes the huge and
um an old standard and uh and he you
know he did all his shtick and roll you
know and what he didn't know is that we
were in commercial
cameras
it was just and
and be really happy to see him and it
was a great moment it was in commercial
and so then he like waved and walked out
and I had to
rush out and tell me no none of that
none of that was on television none of
that so the cameras weren't recording it
anyway well this was the early days and
this is when we had you know we had
these uh I love those guys God bless
their souls but the minute they were in
commercial I think they'd all go have a
martini yeah
you'd be in commercial like today if
something happens in commercial you
still shoot but I think then they
physically left the building and went to
New Jersey
um and had a 35-foot sub
and then made it back
I knew it was a commercial yeah but
anyway I had to go out and tell him he
wasn't too pleased uh did he return for
the taping or no because the moment was
lost he had the big surprise with the
audience so you can't what you can't
resurprise an audience yeah it just
doesn't work yeah uh and so um but
anyway I don't know yeah I wanted to
dash in here
and tell an Old Milton burrow story
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh my God
it's just not happening